Clojure thank you very much for coming
out absolutely the industrialist dilemma
so on what well we'd love to kick off
with we do this in the beginning of each
chat is if you want to kind of give a
you know 30 to 90 seconds sometimes it
goes on to about eight minutes but you
can try to tape to that sort of level
set of the state of financial services
and payments in general and then bring
sort of ease it into the picture of what
you guys are doing kind of right now
around all of that sure
so state of financial services first of
all I'm probably the wrong person to ask
we are and it's actually it's just one
of these big big issues and big
misunderstandings in fact when I first
got to visa there was this big question
inside the company when I got there
people wanted to know in every town hall
are we a financial services company are
we a technology company and the answer
is were definitely not a financial
services company we absolutely have to
act like a technology company but we're
famous business and they're
fundamentally very very different yeah
we don't do it financial services
companies do financial services
companies are our direct clients most
all disturbers our financial service
companies and most acquires in one way
shape or form our financial services
companies the payments industry as you
all know is has gone from this extremely
boring back-office function that no one
ever wanted to talk about right I mean
if you think back to you know think well
if they can remember 10 or 15 years with
you're out buying something I mean
payments wasn't something that was sexy
didn't have startups focusing on
payments it was just something that got
done and you know transactions happened
electronically if you weren't using cash
and today we live in a world where it's
all it's fundamentally changing driven
by Commerce moving to digital platforms
and driven by digital platforms allowing
other people to create either full
networks or parts that value chain that
we talked about and so anyone who's
involved in payments who's not thinking
that the world is fundamentally
different is going to be dead buried and
gone and so there's not in that category
so we're not what are you guys doing
and where where you sort of see
yourselves fitting in the value
proposition of digital payments then
yeah so you all were talking about
whether we needed to be focused on the
digital world and you know the way I
think about it is we partake in commerce
that's what we do we go through all of
the our sales pitches about we
facilitate it we help commerce grow
faster than what that it would with that
it would without us but the reality is
Commerce is moving to digital platforms
if we don't go with it
or even lead it then we will be left far
behind and so the business that we have
today will just it'll take a long time
but it'll be a slow withering away of
our business at some point with some
kind of acceleration so if we want to be
at all as successful as we've been in
the past we need to do it and so for us
it's a fundamental change to our to our
network architecture to who we deal with
which I can get into more detail on what
that actually means and we've got to be
willing to do things quite frankly that
we would have never thought about doing
before and we've gotten so fundamentally
go from this very very closed you know
you talk about a network within visa we
were a very closed operating
infrastructure and that doesn't work in
the world that we're in today can you so
we had some diagrams of the sort of the
transaction process of how payment
actually you know works and and maybe
maybe a 30 second kind of level can you
explain the industrial sort of world
version of that one when things were in
a pre-internet how that worked and do
you think we're in a position where that
should be rebuilt and redone for a
digital world where where there aren't
as many steps in between and in that
future world where do you think visas
value proposition should lie yeah listen
I mean I guess I think that the so just
actually let me just give you a little
intro so you understand the position
that we're in yeah and the frame and
might answer the question so and someone
someone said this before in your
discussion which is we rely on our
relationships with the issuers and the
acquirers
okay and in a lot of ways the issuer's
over a short period of time can have an
extraordinarily meaningful impact on our
business right it's real simple right if
you have a Bank of America card or Wells
Fargo card if they choose not to issue a
Visa card anymore
they're gonna send you a letter that
says throw out your Visa card and
they're gonna send you a someone else's
card and ninety something percent of you
will use that card so the so we have to
be extremely extremely careful about the
role that we play whose feet we step on
to the extent that we do something like
visa checkout which is something which
appears to be direct to consumer there
has to be a good reason for it
or we have to be willing to take on our
clients and remember we have 2.4 billion
cards outstanding in the world and we
have 12,000 people we have 50 million
merchants that accept our products and
with 12,000 people and so we're not told
to as a company on our cell but by
ourselves to deal with this
infrastructure so we are a network but
we rely on networks to help deliver our
products and so it just got we have to
be really thoughtful about what it means
to go beyond that and so when we think
about what happens today I know I mean
it sounds very very complicated we when
you when you draw to me most businesses
what most businesses are much more
complicated when you actually show every
step of what happens otherwise you know
you know you wouldn't be doing what you
do you know so like ultimately when you
look at it right there's a there's a
consumer and there's a merchant and they
want to conduct commerce together and
the merchant has to have a financial
relationship and the consumer has to
have a financial relationship and we
connect them that's what happens and so
fundamentally should that change I
personally think the basic structure of
that is something that will be hard to
change at the scale that we do it there
are absolutely people that can win the
long tail transactions and do things
that are very different than that but
the way in which we go about connecting
and who we connect with and how we
integrate the stipes the the stripes of
the world into what we all do
will fundamentally change who partakes
in that value chain when you look at the
changing payment landscape what do you
think is the biggest change over the
next five to ten years and what's visa
specifically doing about it both
internally and externally yeah so I
guess I'll be back up again so we we
live in three worlds and so I guess you
also has this question a little bit
about priorities and whatnot and there
are three very distinct worlds and we're
not picking and choosing between the
three we're dealing with all three
number one is we do have a traditional
business most of which is physical cards
where we deal with issuers and acquirers
and we've can we compete every single
day with MasterCard and it's gonna be
Union pay in China and its local
networks and it's American Express on Co
brands and they're all tough competition
and if you ask me how I spend my time
there's a more significant portion of my
time than you would expect dealing with
these big relationships because that is
our lifeblood today second piece of it
is the developing world right and so
there is a lot of dark space out there
which is huge opportunity for us and
it's not just Africa its parts of the
United States the United States have two
transactions still aren't electronic
here
so there's and so yes the growth rates
in the US are half of what they are on
the rest of the world but it's a lot of
dollars for us to go after so the idea
of continuing to penetrate electronic
payments of which there's you know when
we went public in 2008 there was
something like the numbers will be
little wrong six or seven trillion
dollars of cash in the world in commerce
today that numbers 11 or 12 so there's
more cash today than there were in
public and we have more means to this
intermediate than ever and so the third
bucket is digital right and it's what I
said before which is we have to deliver
our products and our infrastructure and
the way we do business has to has to
fundamentally change so that we can
integrate with people who were driving
commerce experiences in one way shape or
form and we have to be there in where
digital transactions are taking place
and that's very different from what
we've done the past so not everybody can
win though as we move from
industrial world to the digital one and
so in in this new sort of restructuring
who do you think is under pressure in
that value chain but that we've talked
about or in the ecosystem broadly or
under the most pressure listen I think
all these all these people in the value
chain or our clients more shape the
fairing so yes you know we be careful
here is the honest I think everyone who
is in the flow of that transaction
should be scared to death and you know
you can look at whether it's the bank
whether it is the network whether it's
the acquirer or the equivalents in the
e-commerce world that all should sit
back and say can I be replaced because
the answer is theoretically they can so
what are they doing about it you know I
personally look at the role that we play
and I think in a lot of ways again in
terms of scale because remember we are
you know I always go you always hate to
talk about size because you know the big
dumb and stupid you should kind of go
together a phrase but the fact is things
that scare us are things that can
actually scale across the world in one
way shape or form and when you talk
about that you talk a much more limited
sphere right like cryptocurrency or
crypto currencies is a complex is a
complicated one too it's you know it
because it's it's its blockchain more
than crypto currencies right the
currencies themselves are I find me are
relatively uninteresting they will win
small tail transactions on the margin
very very hard to believe that it'll
scale in a meaningful way across the
globe with governments but blockchain
and especially federated blockchains
do have to you any anyone who has any
kind of a network doesn't matter it's a
payments Network a secure a network we
trade securities real estate titles all
these things you really do need to be
thinking about not just the cost but the
permanent record that gets created with
these that's again I don't put that in
the category of something that we worry
about in the next four or five years but
absolutely
beyond that what so if your customer and
the you're kind of key partner in in
this effort is the bank but the consumer
is the end user and you sort of are
relying on them as a channel do you how
do you deal with the fact that that sort
of you're one step in between the
ultimate consumer of your your
capability and the either the services
that you need to offer and go into I
that you said stepping on people's toes
how do you sort of deal with that whole
you know complexity yeah I mean
delicately I mean it's um you know I
guess first and foremost the resources
and most broadly yeah deal with in such
a way where I have sort of somebody
disrupting you doesn't just go around
that entire process and not have to deal
with the same kind of relationships that
you deal with you know but again someone
need to talk about people going around
us it's like can you just think about
think about how how hard it is for
someone to do everything that you can to
connect two and a half billion people
with 50 million merchants in you know
two hundred some-odd locations around
the world and people it's and so there
are domestic networks across the world
so you go to Canada there is a domestic
debit network called in Iraq you go to
Australia there's a domestic network
called F paws there are domestic
networks but number one is they're not
interoperable across the world and so
anyone who has one of those cards that
travels across the border needs a
another branded card and their
capabilities aren't anything close to
what a real network would have and so
there are severe limitations to what
these individual networks can provide
for and so again so we so we have this
amongst you all I hate to say we have
this incumbent advantage that we really
have to use to our advantage and if all
we do is why the incumbent advantage it
will be disaster but having that gives
us a fair amount of lead time to pivot
in different directions so specifically
with that incumbent advantage
what's visa doing differently now I
would say when you join three and a half
years ago or even versus five years ago
sure what's your team doing difference
so take them so historically we would
only talk to an issuer or an acquire
what I mean like we wouldn't talk to
anyone literally if we would get a call
from at
well that would say listen we got this
great idea we want to work on Apple pay
we're good we would say that's great why
don't you go talk to you know the 15,000
banks that we deal with and go talk to
all the acquires we deal with and when
you have contracts and when you set up
standards with all of them come back and
talk to us
that's literally what we've done
historically and so what we've done is
number one is we have started to treat a
much broader set of people again people
who can insert themselves into commerce
or into the payment streams as people
that we should have relationships with
and to figure out how we can bring
people into the payment stream in a way
which I would describe as friendly to us
and our clients we also have the benefit
of there are a lot of people that are
not far from this campus that have tried
to step into the role of a network and
of a bank has it worked out and now they
are doing things which are much more
friendly the ecosystem because they
don't necessarily want to make money
lesson just from payments they want to
do what they do yes right they want to
sell devices they want to bring people
into their ecosystem and you know
payments is a way to solidify that and
the question is do they want to do with
a regulation that the banks have
absolutely not and so in a funny way
regulation well I can talk about what we
like and don't like about it it does
provide a barrier entry to some people
who just know better than they go there
where so Apple calls you and they say
hey we're doing this Apple pay thing
what and you have an ecosystem centric
approach so you take the call and and
you know you don't sort of pass along to
the 15,000 banks where do you are you
generating new value because of that
kind of partnership where do you do you
live in a stack in a different place
because of Apple pay or Google Android
pay or what what has changed out your
business model then because of that you
know the one so the most significant
thing that we did with him is we created
tokenization which is just a fancy way
for randomizing your account number so
that it can sit on a mobile device in a
way that we're all comfortable with so
that device is compromised your countess
and compromised but beyond that what we
do and this is what you know networks do
and we by the way we work with
MasterCard American Express and even
discover on things like this which is we
want to create opens
standards so that we can define how
accounts are provisioned on to devices
how the transaction flow then works
because the tokenize transaction flow is
very different than when you're when
you've got the account number flight
across the payment system and we want to
make it easy for ever to participate in
that so think about it as you know we've
got the platform but we you know we
create the standards by which all these
transactions can flow so that we do that
with Apple we MasterCard the rest agree
on what those standards are and then
very very easy for any bank in the world
or any merch in the world to come be
part of the ecosystem without us doing
that again it would have to be
one-on-one conversations and someone
would have to try and set the standard
and we have the ability to do that are
you so with anything that could do how I
guess been the longer term 5-10 years
out how worried are you about things
that could disintermediate a bunch of
though that that in between sort of
transaction area so if Google entered
and directly connected small businesses
with with the consumer and and sort of
the entire payment stack was just you
know the old form of payments in the
industrial world where we had to have
the network just goes away because you
can actually connect the buyer and
seller together is that a real threat
and you have to do anything today to
sort of worry about that
yeah listen I mean I don't I mean we I
mean we as a company worry every single
day right so I say things I'm worried
about not worried about you know things
we're not worried about we spend a
tremendous amount of time more so than
any other place I've ever worked in any
other job the things that we think we're
not worried about we still spend a
tremendous amount of time on saying do
we have it right do we have it wrong
what's different today than yesterday
because the world is changing so
dramatically and I I think we're in a
good position today and again part of
what we want to do is to the extent that
you can you know you there if there are
people out there that theoretically can
do some can can make these connections
then what you want to do is we want to
it's in our interest to work with them
to have them believe there's a better
way for them to go about doing their
business I really believe it is better
for them to partner with us than to do
what we do
on their own right and then they'll see
it themselves so if the three of us were
sitting here five years from now and it
all went horribly wrong
you know something new some big
disruption what would be your best guess
is that what went wrong that would have
hurt visa best biggest disruption but we
haven't talked about security security
security is paramount to who we are so
we you know when we think about who we
are and why people trust the visa brand
is because is because they actually
trust the transaction they trust that
you can use the card that it's going to
work it's gonna work quickly and it's
safe and secure and if something goes
wrong it will be fixed because of the
rules that we have on our ecosystem so
as we open up access to our capabilities
which yes the question I don't really
talk about in the past which is things
that we're changing our in addition to
working with people like apples in the
world is we're opening up our
capabilities through api's which we
never allowed anyone other than an issue
or an acquire to get access to to
integrate our capabilities into there
they're ultimately commerce experiences
whatever whatever those are and that
changes the whole security game for us
because when you have a very close
network which we've had which is exactly
what it was as you all know much easier
to control than when you start opening
up your universe to the world were there
people inside a visa who didn't want you
to open up your API absolutely how did
you handle that they're no longer here
well listen I think it's one of these no
in all seriousness and I say that I mean
these are i think i think we're blessed
to have great people at the company and
just to give you an idea of the growth
when we went public we had 3,500 people
in 2008 and we have 12,500 today so in
addition to turnover just brought a lot
of people in from the outside some
through acquisitions small number 1500
the rest through the growth that we've
had and so we've been able to bring in
the types of people that either have the
skills or think about the world the way
we're thinking about the world and the
fact is most of the people come in to
visa they want to do a great job they
know
something and they're very open-minded
and there's some people and generally it
isn't work people you know it's it's the
people to senior levels because they
know one thing that do things one way
and the world has to change and I
actually you know and when you look at
our management team it's about a third
people who've been at visa for a long
time it's a third people that got there
when the company went public and it's
like the third people that I brought in
not by design that's the way it turns
out and I think actually it's a great
mix how much of your time has to be
spent on then the new initiatives like
you know obviously they have this
complex job because you've got regular
you know you have regulators you have
partners you have traditional
competitors you have new markets and
then you have the whole digital strategy
how do you sort of spend your time to
make sure that you're putting the right
allocation in the areas that you think
are going to end me most important yeah
so so here's right so it's it I spend so
let me say it this way you have I have
to fight to spend time on issues like
this because like any other job you can
see how you sit there and there are
always issues there owes problems
generally when and when and our
partnerships with banks we're probably
the largest partner because of what we
of what they pay us and we control
interchange so you know when it comes to
dealing with the bank the bank's want to
deal with the CEO they don't want to
deal with someone else and so you can
get sucked into spending all your time
doing that but you need to force I need
to force myself to make sure I'm putting
the time in I also you know after every
CEO as this I travel 65 percent of the
time 60 to 70 percent of the time and
wherever I go I spend a third of the
time with clients a third of the time
with government because it's so
important and a third of the time on
internal activities probably spit split
25% between just like a normal business
review of results what's going on and
then try and do 75% on what's really
going on in the market because we're
good because we're talking about
payments like it's one business it's
extraordinarily different across the
world you know someone talked about
Africa the way the way payments are the
way digital payments are conducted and
what the opportunities and the solutions
that will work in Africa are very
different than in Indonesia very
different Vietnam very different in
Brazil you
the development world the United States
Canada Australia much much more similar
but the opportunity for us is much
broader than the developed world what I
probably see your time in the kind of
organizational structure and sort of
having to make sure that people are then
spending their time on them may be the
the most important and potentially the
the most disruptive things have you had
to create any either
sort of organizational units that are
separate from the core business that are
either doing disruptive things or doing
things that have a different margin
structure or different you know
technical set of capabilities to ensure
like how is that played out how is that
has that worked so early on yes so I
first got to visa absolutely there was a
call like a ring-fenced group that did
all of these things that were out of the
ordinary course for visa because the
fact is the organisation would kill it
and I mean they'll try I mean every
little thing whether it's because we
can't do this because of technology we
can't do this in pricing because of what
it's going to do to everything else and
you know in the way organizations kill
things is by not getting things done and
so absolutely we you know controlled
resources clear mandate and it's and I
don't mean it this way because we are a
management team but it was like we were
gonna die can other people weren't gonna
stand in the way and that was very very
clear I think now it's somebody it's
four years later what I feel great about
is it's not what part of the business
did that have to happen in what was
reinvest well any anything having to do
with things that were involved us in
digital or where we were dealing with
new what we would call clients other
than issuers and acquirers like
developers anything whether it's whether
it's sales people or relationship people
that are talking to the amazons in the
world the Google's the Facebook's
whether it's people that are building
out the api's for the ISV community I
mean any anything which was different
just ring-fenced into a group that's
very different today by the way how did
you manage the cultural implication of
oh here's the future and the exciting
stuff in your work
the old stuff and you know just we're in
a cash cow you and the best in the
temperature yeah usually I mean I'll
tell what I did because there's no doubt
that that is the huge risk in it
everywhere I go every Town Hall every
conversation always talked about the
importance of the existing business so I
just did a town hall last week across
the whole company the first thing I
talked about with all the stuff going on
in payments the first thing I talked
about is the holiday season the boring
holiday season where we had a hundred
percent availability yeah you know we
increased our ability to process
transactions up to fifty six thousand
transactions a second and it's flawless
and we have because we got huge swathes
of people inside the company that worked
their butts off to do that and so
appreciation respect and transfer that
to because we've been so successful at
doing these things that gives us the
license to go do all these other things
and over a period of time akan stantly
explain why those things are important
and we've even had people come in from
the outside we had a brand new client
come in and talk about why they chose us
over someone else and how they think
about us versus just other generic
options out there and they talk about
they'll talk about the processing they
don't talk about the fact that like we
can clear and settle their transactions
they talk about all the other
value-added things that we're doing to
help them navigate the world of balance
hmm so you're the sort of trusted
partner across all these different
dimensions for for those players yeah
what when you please just one thing I
will say there was one thing I feel
great about inside the organization is
it's not ring-fenced anymore it's not
it's fully integrated because that's the
way we think that's the way we think and
so you know we've got you know the
people developing what we call the visa
developer Center which our API stack the
people who are working on these outside
everything is integrated to the company
and it's just as part of the
conversation now because people
understand that's what we need to do be
successful right you guys have now
famously invested in
fairly disruptive started startups in
the payment space
I think Square was just announced and
certainly stripe is an investment you
guys are done how do you a strategically
I guess why you're doing that and mom
you see partnering with with these
digital companies and potentially an
investing or eventually even maybe M&A
how do you sort of prioritize all of
that you know so I mean they're all a
little bit different I think so I mean
so you talked about Square we we
invested in Square area we actually
missin Square a long time ago we
invested in it because we believed that
they could do something which would help
grow electronic payments and the fact is
we sit here today you know just a couple
of years later square I didn't know the
current number now but something like
seven or eight million people accept our
products that never were able to accept
them before and so it's so and everyone
was talking about ask where do we like
them or not like and we love square
right square also cash squared absolute
Square does a great job in providing
value back to the merchants so we did
that because we wanted to give the
endorsement to something which we
thought could be really helpful to help
and grow the market and yes obviously
we'd like to make a little money
alongside stripe is something very
different
I think stripe is a and stripe inside
the company was a little controversial
not because they compete with our core
business they don't but we we bought a
company called cyber source that owned a
company called authorized.net that
theoretically does what stripe does
meaning they enable merchants to accept
payments and to manage the payments in
EECOM and mobile that's that's what they
that's what they do
the RIA and it's it's a great company
great people great acquisition we've
done really really well the reality is
stripes better they're faster
they are very tightly focused on the app
space in a way that we've been slow to
and so that one we step back and look at
it and yeah we want to make some money
number two we actually want to have a
commercial relationship with them
because they do just a piece of what we
do and we're not going to be able have
100% of that part of the business so
find that we compete with them but we
want we want to be their third partner
as because we have belief in them as the
you saw Patrick they're just they're
smart quality people that just get
things to market that work better than
other things in the marketplace and
probably the most important which I
talked about opens up inside the company
is we can learn a lot from them what
there's a great video online of us talk
more if you want to learn more things
from Patrick what one of the new
ecosystems that you sort of touched on
is the developer ecosystem kind of it
feels like that would have been
brand-new for Visa in the past five or
ten years do you see that as a I guess
how do you think about that that that
vectors is that a growth factor for you
guys can you monetize that differently
what what is visa as a platform company
versus a network for four payments you
know so it's a so you say it new for us
five or ten years ago the fact is we
literally the week before the Super Bowl
we announced the opening of our
development center right we are like we
are as late as late can be to this party
but having said that when I say that
well it's true yeah it's got to be
honest about it yeah but we've got but
having said that we're not I mean we're
late to the party but it's I don't think
well the fact that we're doing it well
we've got lots of opportunity and we'll
do just fine listen it goes back to what
is it what is visa as a platform we are
so yes we do all the things that a
network does we've got you know we
connect buyers and sellers and whatnot
but the fact is we don't get paid what
we get paid and we're not gonna be able
to survive unless we can convince an
individual a bank and ultimately the
merchant that it's better for you to run
your transaction over our network than
anything else it doesn't matter whether
it's MasterCard American Express
something that's ACH related and
blockchain main and anything you want to
imagine and so for that we need to
provide value in that and that can take
any any any one of a number of ways so
we've done that for a long period of
time but we've done it in terms of
things that we've built ourselves or the
banks and acquires so we've always done
a great job on fraud right so and you so
when that card is swiped or dipped or
tapped across the world
we know obviously who you are we know
where you are we know if you've been
there before we know generally what type
of store it is we know where you were
you know if you used your card and in a
reasonable period so we know all those
things and we help people determine
where there's fraud which so I front is
so low even with all the conversations
it's still nice to everything got to
drive it to zero we've always done a
great job and most of the other payment
systems out there especially that are
focused on ACH don't do that and so it
might sound it's a very boring thing but
it's a tremendous amount of money and
the risks are getting bigger and bigger
and then you add to that things like
we're seeding capabilities I mean we see
the transactions you know right now you
wait until the end of the month to get
your statement or if you have Apple you
can get something there they're really
neat things that people would do with
that you know think about people people
whose eco systems that you're on all the
time and would you like to have your
information in one place how would you
like it to look how would you like that
receipt to be integrated with something
else you might want to do or something
you've already done so and the point of
view for us is listen that's not what we
do for a living we've we've we've done
some of those things in the past but
because we're this platform because we
have these capabilities we want to open
up the development you know the the
ability to develop off these
capabilities just a whole host of people
we still will control how they actually
get brought to market but we don't want
to monetize it it doesn't mean that
we'll never monetize it but the fact is
and I say this very publicly right which
is we make plenty of money on processing
transactions as you pointed out okay
what we need to do is come in every
single day and continue to convince
people reconvince them that that value
is there and you do that by continuing
to build experiences and add value
whether it's on risk whether it's on
marketing which on customer experience
awesome
okay Charlie sure thank you very much
absolutely